Jamie Lee Curtis apparently she won an
Oscar and she's naming her Oscar or
she's using the Oscar's preferred
pronouns of they them because of her
trans son or daughter take a look
here they are have we named her what's
her I I'm I'm in support of my daughter
Ruby I'm I'm having them be obey them oh
um I'm I'm gonna just call them them and
um they are doing great a Hollywood
actress hugging and stroking her
ridiculous award in honor of her trans
child is just like the perfect it's just
perfect I think we have a picture of her
they themed daughter or son
I will leave that without commentary
because my mom's probably watching and
she wants me to be nicer so we'll let
that be uh but it never ends it never
ends with these people